you guys have shared some of your
personal lives online when you have to
address things in your personal life
what is that moment that you go oh I
have to talk about this with my fans for
me it's when people already know and
they're like when you gonna say
something I feel like you have to
address pretty much everything because
we are such like an open book on the
internet and like part of being a
digital influencer it's like sharing
every aspect of your life I think if
they'll notice it and incessantly
comment about it where it'll drive you
crazy you need to address it I think
they're there are certain lines they
have to set for yourself but I get why
people need to announcer and things like
that so that's a big partier life
sometimes it's a back-and-forth where
it's like I don't owe anyone an
explanation but at the same time like
you put so much of the good out there
that was something bad does happen you
kind of you feel like you owe an
explanation as well it's very simple I
do what I want when things start going
south it's already tough enough to deal
with the relationship and all its
problems by yourself but when you have a
whole audience judging you or leaving
comments trying to depict what you do
with your life it makes it really
difficult I've gone through breakups and
it's very hard then all of a sudden
people stop seeing these people on your
photos and like what happened to that
guy and then you're with a new guy and
like what a [ __ ] you know but like is
she dating 10 men like you have to kind
of clarify like what's going on
otherwise people are like you know
Brittany prom dates 15 guys which is
true I mean for me I think the bigger I
kid and the bigger this world gets like
it's almost like the less I want to
share just because it's personal you
want to keep it private but at the same
time like I want to be real and I don't
want to take anything I'm like
relationships I am like that's for me
family stuff that's for me
but it depends and I think each person
it spends for them too I have nothing to
hide nothing to lose and my viewers are
my friends and when I'm getting through
things my beers can help me with their
tweets and inspire me and even though
I've been through some hard times and
you know their creators out there the
viewers that love you are so much more
abundant and it's kind of like they're
they're like you have like a million
children like they're your children like
they've seen you grow as a person but
they only know a specific part of your
life they don't see like the other parts
that make a relationship so it's very
confusing for people that are invested
in a relationship would be like but I
thought everything was great you know
it's like a relationship there's more to
a relationship than what happens on
camera so it's tough even if you're
watching daily videos you really don't
know it all and what creators choose to
give to you you should respect my advice
would be if you're showing a
relationship show all the bad parts to
then people hope you blown away by the
fact that you're breaking up you like
hold up hold up we're having a really
bad argument let me just skip it all
right but it's always hard it's never
fun there's no easy way to do it and can
you imagine it sucks but it's part of
the drama again thanks for watching ET
on youtube if you want more make sure to
subscribe